a lot of words to describe you social
media mogul entrepreneur internet
personality all this stuff how would you
describe yourself i think i'm an
entrepreneur
somebody asked me today in an interview
what do i do with my down time
i told them that i start other
businesses
this is my hobby this is my passion this
is what i love to do i love building
businesses this is fun for me
you understand i'm a purebred
entrepreneur for real for real for real
like documented
how did this all start what happened
with me is i had the
great benefit of being an immigrant i
was born in belarus
in the former soviet union and uh came
to the states in 78
set up in queens and my parents lived
the american dream they worked
very hard my dad was a stock boy in a
liquor store in clark new jersey and
eventually saved up enough money to buy
a store in springfield new jersey
i was lemonade stands baseball cards
real hustler kid anything to make a buck
and at 14 i got dragged into the store
heard the internet
my freshman year of college heard that
sound cooch
knew that it was special and in 1996 i
launched one of the first e-commerce
wine businesses in america called
winelibrary.com took over my dad's
business kind of running it day to day
in 1998 alongside with him
and from 98 to 2003 uh helped grow that
business from a three to a 60 million
dollar business
but growing up business from three to
sixty million was just the beginning
let's see what gary created after
leaving wine library
i was 34 years old
when i started vaynermedia i had spent
the 12 best years of my
youth building my dad's liquor store for
him i left that business had no money
had no equity i was worthless
to the bank vaynermedia started in
somebody else's conference room because
we had no money for rent so it was a ton
of risk
by normal standards when somebody reads
it on paper
but not necessarily for me it just felt
like progression
i run vaynermedia we are an 800 person
firm
100 million dollars in revenue and four
years from zero we work with
ge and pepsi and under armour and toyota
and the biggest brands in the world what
does avena media do
we're a modern day mad men we're a
madison avenue agency the same people
that used to sell
commercial time on anything you ever did
in radio and television we now do that
on facebook snapchat instagram and we
produce the creative for the brands
to sell stuff through the phone we are
living through
a revolution this my friends
this is the television
and the television is the radio and it's
1960
and there's a huge opportunity what does
being a contemporary communicator
mean it means that you understand where
people are paying attention
whether that's twitch or tick tock or
believe it or not
organic reach on linkedin and then are
you capable of creating the creative
the videos the pictures the written
words that are contextual
to those platforms to make the agenda
successful vaynermedia grew into a
global advertising agency with five
offices
across new york london singapore
los angeles and chattanooga tennessee as
time went on
gary created vaynerx a modern
communications holding company
that houses different ventures like the
gallery media group
the sasha group vayner productions
tracer
vaynercommerce and vayner speakers gary
also continues to build other businesses
after four years of building resi a
restaurant reservation app it sold for
nine figures to american express in
2019.
gary is also an extremely strong
business collaborator
in 2017 he became the face of k-swiss
his collaboration helped contribute to
their 200 million dollar plus
exit in 2019. shopping cart below if
you're not buying this
you're breaking my heart he's also a
co-founder of empathy wines
which was recently acquired by
constellation brands so you just created
empathy
last year yeah this is one of those one
plus one equals 11 where both sides of
the equation bring so much value
ceo gary's the chief executive officer
of vaynerx
but how would gary describe what he does
at its most purest sense i am an
operating entrepreneur so let's take a
deeper look into what drives gary and
how he operates
i'm a kid who started working literally
the day i left college
i walked into wine library about six
o'clock that night
worked for two hours then went home and
literally from that moment literally the
day i left college
to the second i'm sitting here right now
i have never not
been the chief operator of a business
and i've made payroll every single week
since i was 22 years old and i'm proud
of that because it's practical as [ __ ]
i've taken vaynermedia as the ceo and
ceo for that matter
i've operated it every day i've taken it
from zero to 200 million
in revenue with no cash infusion started
it in a conference room
it's now my second company that i built
and what i want to do is inspire
two 14 year old girls in kansas city
right now to build a billion dollar
company
on having a bunch of employees hugging
each other in the halls
and it is not lost on me that i am
taking the gifts that my mom and dad
gave me
and i'm giving them to the world and my
happiness framework
and the way i treat people is for some
reason
becoming cool and if and i'm just gonna
squeeze the [ __ ] out of that
because it's leading to good i know i'm
on to something so fundamentally
different
and i know that i can inspire people to
do it because it's gonna have the
empire part two see that's what people
don't get
the reason i'm gonna win is because i've
got both
the honey part means that you wanna go
change the world
the empire part means you'll do it at
all costs
i'm neither gary has a natural ability
to see consumer trends
which led him to be an early investor in
companies like uber
twitter tumblr facebook snapchat and
venmo
i am predicting that facebook acquires
instagram
15 million users for instagram probably
gonna push 30 next year
and i just have this funny feeling that
zucks is going to look at that talent
look at that app bring it in house so i
was on pierce morgan
his opening line is this company's 550
days old
how the hell is it worth a billion
dollars and my opening line is they
stole it
i get out of the studio and literally
there are thousands of tweets
of people calling me a [ __ ] idiot and
then i guess last year this time right
uh facebook bought whatsapp for 18
billion and
every article like the next day after
the news came out is like oh wait a
minute
they [ __ ] stole instagram and more
recently
gary predicted this acquisition when joe
rogan inevitably announces that he
paid 100 million dollars to exclusively
be on whatever
platform he's going to go on i have a
funny feeling everyone's going to be
like wait a minute i have an
announcement
the podcast is moving to spotify gary's
also involved in a variety of
organizations
like charity water pencils of promise
bojangles
mcmack the all-in challenge the
minnesota rocker
vaynersports and more now let's take a
deeper look into gary's personal brand
at garyvee gary vaynerchuk aka
vee is a self-help media mogul one of
gary's core beliefs as a marketer
is that every company and human being is
a media company first
because of that he built team garyvee a
team of strategists
video editors writers and designers to
help him grow his personal brand
gary's been putting out content for 10
plus years across the platforms of the
time
starting with wine content with wine
library tv
then he moved to hosting the askgaryvee
show a q a show between gary and his
audience
then he started documenting his life's
journey through dailyvee and weeklyv
like it's so obvious to me what's gonna
happen with dailyvee it's gonna be so
[ __ ] crazy
what it all looks like a year from today
and he also
started a live stream q a show called t
with garyvee
gary is also a five times new york times
best-selling author
and travels across the world for
keynotes and has a top business podcast
where he talks to some of the biggest
entrepreneurs investors
artists and thought leaders of our time
[Music]
when gary vaynerchuk retires or goes off
from the sunset
what do you want to be meant for that i
gave more than i took
i really want to be remembered for that
you